bon
[Musique]
il
mathieu palun vous êtes journaliste
écrivain auteur de deux livres dont le
deuxième ne t'arrête pas de courir a été
multi récompensé notamment par le prix
interallié l'histoire fascinante d'une
graine de champion échoué en prison le
récit qu'ils ont fait est absolument
renversant en ceci qu partent à la
rencontre d'un homme en quête de sa
vérité mais c'est contre vous même que
vous vous gagnez pourrais vous dire que
ce livre c'est à la fois c'est d'abord
le récit d'une double rencontre avec soi
même et avec l'autre des deux côtés du
parloir autrement dit une sorte de
miroir inversé
c'est une eau début je pensais que
j'allais faire un livre sur l'athlétisme
sur un champion avec une histoire
extraordinaire et en fait je me suis je
me rends compte maintenant d'ailleurs ce
que quand on me demande une dédicace
dans le livre je dis toujours ça que
c'est un livre sur l'amitié finalement
bien plus que sur l'athlétisme sur la
prison ou l'enfermement
parce que c'est vrai que je suis allé
rencontrer un inconnu dans un parloir
chose qui n'existe pas au parloir on va
soutenir un proche
et très vite il s'est passé ce qui se
passe parfois quand on rencontre un
inconnu et on sait pas pourquoi il prend
un peu mieux la lumière dans un bar
n'importe où et on se dit tiens c'est
comme si je le connaissais déjà et sur
une phéromone aussi peut-être peut-être
maître magnée en tout cas c'est ce qui
s'est passé dans un parloir et je suis
sorti de là au bout d'une heure puisque
c'est le temps accordé et j'avais qu'une
envie c'était de revenir
vous dites que c'est un livre sur
l'amitié c'est aussi un livre sur la
rédemption
ci serait on tenté de dire si ce n'était
pas aussi connoté en tout cas sur une
limitation la mutation d'un homme frappé
par la grâce mais qui se sa botte
jusqu'à ce que la justice le rattrape
oui thomas lycée bah c'est un grand
champion
multirécidiviste beaucoup de gens ont eu
envie de le secouer comme un prunier en
lisant arrête de déconner parce que il a
beaucoup cambrioler mais il fait partie
de ces gens qui ont un don du ciel
quelque chose qui leur tombent dessus
savent pas comment ils font c les génies
et ils courent naturellement très vite
et rentrer naturellement sans faire
d'effort en équipe de france mais pour
autant il continue les conneries toutes
les nuits il vole dans les bureaux de
tabac 50 euros dans une pharmacie et à
tel point que les gens se demandent au
tour de autour de lui ses entraîneurs
ses proches qu'est ce qui le pousse à
faire ça parce que c'est pas comme un
jeune qui tombe dans le trafic de drogue
qui rêvent de roule en lamborghini c'est
c'est des petits larcins c'est de la
petite délinquance mais qui lui coûte
très cher au final il s'est retrouvé
avec une peine de prison de 2 13 ans 13
ans et une peine pour un braquage à main
armé alors qu' il était tout seul à
faire les fonds de caisse quoi alors
qu'est ce qui le poussa fallait fond de
caisse et qu'est ce qui vous pousse à
hanter les prisons vous avez passé
beaucoup beaucoup de temps dans les
centres de rétention pour essayer de
comprendre comment des hommes et des
femmes résister au système carcéral
quelle conclusion en êtes vous arrivé
c'est l'éternelle question ce que la
prison abîme ou réparé
la prison abymes et j'ai pas
d'hésitation à répondre ça parce que
l'enfermement abymes peu importe les
conditions dans lesquelles vous êtes
enfermé de base l'enfermement vous
abymes le temps est plus long le sens de
la peine et de la vie aussi comment ça
se floute et on se demande ce qu'on fait
là et est
donc
la question que je venais chercher moi
en allant rencontrer toumani c'était
pourquoi un mec aussi talentueux a tout
gâché et est il possible de se soigner
quand on a cette maladie là qu'est ce
que lui à l'appel l'addiction au vol
l'addiction c'est la spirale infernale
du délinquant c'est celui qui arrive pas
à s'en sortir je vous reviens sur la
prison si l'on en croit le dernier
rapport de dominique simonnot la
contrôleuse général des lieux de
privation de liberté c'est un joli nom
pudiquement on appelle ça comme ça
aujourd'hui
effectivement la prison bousies esquinte
déglingué seulement elle dit rien est
réuni pour que les gens en sortent
meilleurs ils en sortiront pire que vous
inspire ce diagnostic c'est exactement
ce que j'ai vu en fait ça fait dix ans -
qu'en tant que journaliste j'ai la
chance de pouvoir rentrer en prison de
rencontrer
des détenus qu'on tous âges j'ai
rencontré des gamins de 18 ans qui était
déjà abîmés par la vie des types qu'on
avait 70 et qui arrivait même plus à se
souvenir de l'époque où il n'était pas
en prison et quand je suis allé voir
toumani j'avais la certitude que la
prison il fallait il fallait la détruire
et trouver une autre forme de punition
et je continue encore à penser ça m'est
rhmani a déjoué ce pronostic même si
tous manier à déjouer ces pronostics
parce que parce qu'il est l'un des seuls
on est vous avez parlé de rédemption kim
est prouvé qu'il était possible de
changer en prison je pense que c'est
l'exception qui confirme la règle c'est
quelqu'un qui a une force mentale
incroyable qui est capable en prison la
prison c'est que de la souffrance c'est
de la souffrance au quotidien c'est de
la souffrance la nuit et malgré ça il a
réussi à s'ajouter encore de la
discipline et de la souffrance en
continuant les entraînements on va en
parler mais se disant le jour où je
sortirai jeu serait justement pas pire
mes meilleurs alors à quoi sert
l'enfermement c'est une question qui
vous hante que vous n'avez pas vraiment
résolu mais j'aimerais d'abord parlé de
cet athlète au parcours et au destin
hors du commun parce que au parlant lui
ou à parler de vous
comment d'abord est né ce livre mathieu
pas là
je tendais dire par hasard et il y en a
probablement jamais mais je lisais un
jeu parcours est un journal le parisien
pour ne pas le nommer qui citait toumani
coulibaly 30 ans j'avais 30 ans moi
aussi ou 28 peut-être et il était cité à
son procès et c'était son 15e déjà
procès pourtant bricolage et au lieu de
s'adresser au juge il s'adressait à la
presse en dix ans
s'il vous plaît faites attention à ce
que vous allez écrire parce que mon fils
aîné a appris à lire je sais que ça va
lui faire du mal et cette petite phrase
là
je sais pas pourquoi elle m'a touché
voilà pourquoi avoir choisi d'en faire
un livre plutôt qu'à un reportage au
long cours comme vous avez l'habitude
d'en faire pour libération où les revues
21 ou six mois pourquoi un livre parce
qu'un livre c'est
ça la liberté déjà c'est vous qui
décidez de ce que vous allez mettre
dedans et c'est aussi l'un team c'est
qu'est ce que vous avez dans les tripes
de ce qui vous taraude suffisamment pour
que ça termine dans un livre et moi dans
un article annonçait coulera entre votre
lettre adressée à tous mais nico du
bailli et sa réponse entre temps vous
démissionnez de la revue 21 vous
désespérez du métier au point de vouloir
tout quitter de devenir prof de ps vous
étiez vous-même à la croisée des chemins
ce moment là oui parce que j'étais en
colère en 2018
j'avais l'impression en fait de plus
avoir ma place dans ce métier je suis
pas sûr d'avoir vraiment changé d'avis
là-dessus d'air mais pourquoi parce
qu'on a vu 21 j'étais un gosse de riche
dans un cocon j'étais salarié d'une
revue qui faisait du reportage comme on
en faisait ya cent ans on en voyant
quelqu'un vous fait-elle d'alors voilà
avec des conditions de reportage
extrêmement
extrait extrêmement belle et qui
n'existe plus aiea reportables
confortable et en démissionnant de ce
poste-là j'avais la certitude que
j'étais plus employables parce que
j'avais eue tout tout de suite et que
aucun autre journal de rides et trop
gâté jeune anglais trop gâté d'emblée et
donc
peut-être que ma voix était ailleurs et
dans le sport c'était ma première
c'était mes premières ambitions quand
j'étais encore adolescent et le
professorat de ps je l'avais très
sérieusement envisagée moi je me disais
il est pas trop tard physiquement tu es
encore en forme tu peux mais vous tomber
sur un os c'est à dire un sujet en or
cet athlète champion de france du 400 m
qui boivent qui va vous faire replonger
alors un athlète effectivement vous
disiez promis à une médaille olympique
qui gâche toutes ces choses
systématiquement en allant après chacune
de ses victoires cambriolé des bureaux
de tabac vous l'avez dit des boutiques
de téléphonie des supermarchés des
pharmacies pourquoi ces cris fiton un
tel avenir à de menus larcins c'est pour
répondre à cette question de télé à réau
tous les mercredis pendant deux ans
ouais en fait je plus je rencontrais
toumani
plus j'avais de questions parce que je
me destinais tous les pans de sa vie que
je n'avais pas connu c'est à dire les 30
premières années de sa vie et j'ai
essayé d'y déceler un peu comme dans un
roman d'agatha christie on cherche le
coupable et les êtres humains sont en
général un peu plus complexe et des
coupables y en a plusieurs donc il faut
trouver à quel moment ça déconne et dans
sa vie à quel moment il a trébuché pour
qu'ils prennent systématiquement la
mauvaise décision alors que ce qui
m'apparaissait comme étant éclatant
c'était son intelligence et je misais
les gens intelligents ne peuvent pas
prendre systématiquement les mauvaises
décisions
il ya dû avoir quelque chose il faut que
je le trouvais donc tous les mercredis
j'avais nouvelle question parce que je
me disais un peu comme un enquêteur
quand il faut que bout d'un moment je
vais trouver lors de votre toute
première rencontre vous emporter dans
votre poche
l'attrape-coeur de salinger pour lui
offrir pourquoi ce livre
à l'attrape-coeurs c1 c'est le livre qui
m'a le plus bluffé je pense des livres
que j'ai lus parce que peut-être pas
aussi parce que je partais d'un mauvais
a priori cette couverture rouge un peu
rose avec ce nom l'attrape-coeurs j'ai
pendant longtemps et est persuadé que
c'était un livre à l'eau de rose au
moins deux gars et quand je suis tombé
dessus et que j'allais vraiment ouvert
ça m'a retourné le cerveau et j'avais la
certitude que je l'aimé beaucoup à faire
je lui ai offert à tous les gens que je
rencontrais et toumani n'a pas fait
exception je lui ai offert le livre et
je voulais qu'il le lise parce que le
héros de ce livre holden c'est un gamin
de 17 ans qui cherche sa place dans mon
qui n'est pas à l'aise dans son lycée
qui n'est pas à l'aise dans sa famille
qu'est n'est pas à l'aise dans la ville
mais qui a l'air extrêmement intelligent
et qui
assemble déceler un secret qu'on est
tous m'anime me semblait
alors sa place dans le monde toumani
coulibaly va la chercher longtemps
cinquième d'une fratrie de dix huit
enfants il commence à voler très tôt dès
le cp des tamagotchis des gameboy décédé
il est en cm1 quand il se confronte à sa
première garde à vue sa mère lui
assènera cette phrase étrange qui se
transformera en prophétie auto
réalisatrice
tu as la main qu'ils veulent
ouais oui tu l'as la toile à main qui
vole je pense que c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure
le meilleur conseil à donner un voleur
parce que tu vas presque une assignation
à la main qui volent c'est sais tu ne
peux rien y faire et c'est ce n'est pas
de ta faute puisque c'est à main et
l'extérieur toi c'est extérieur à toi tu
peux rien y faire voilà ça te dépasse et
toumani d'ailleurs si des mots qu'il a
prononcés ça me dépasse
la vérité c'est que aujourd'hui
après des années de prison des années de
souffrance des années de solitude
je pense qu'il a compris que cette
affirmation
méritait d'être questionné qu'il était
possible de le remettre en cause - de la
remettre en cause mais après des années
de prison et aussi tout un travail
réflexif à la fois exception avec
lui-même et avec vous pour en trouver
une autre de place et pourrait pour se
défaire de cette pulsion oui c'est je
connais pas du tout le travail des psys
et mais à un moment on s'est retrouvé
dans un peu comme là on se retrouve
c'est à dire dans une pièce nue avec
juste deux chaises et deux personnes qui
se regardent dans le blanc des yeux avec
rien d'autre à faire que de se parler et
de se rencontrer et je sentais que
peut-être j'avais ma place là dedans
alors que j'arrivais un peu comme un
cheveu sur la soupe dans une histoire
qui n'était pas la mienne parce que en
le faisant raconter son histoire
je le faisais à coucher aussi peut-être
d'une douleur qui lui pesait et d'une
certaine manière je me rencontre est un
peu moi même aussi je me sens us anti
d'un coup légitimement raconter cette
histoire là parce que je j'ai réalisé
grâce à tout m'a dit que
j'avais une obsession on va en parler de
la prison et
que peut-être c'était ma porte d'entrée
pour écrire cette histoire alors on va
arriver à vous à travers toumani mais
encore quelques mots sur too many to
many a continué vous le disiez à
s'entraîner sans relâche dans les murs
alors que ses chances de compétition
semblait compromise ne serait-ce que au
regard de son âge la course ça a été
aussi un facteur de résilience pour lui
oui c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le
livre s'appelle ne t'arrête pas de
courir vous parce que
parce que finalement c'est quelqu'un qui
sait de se définit comme n'ayant aucune
passion
ce qui est étrange déjà de rencontrer
quelqu'un qui n'a aucune passion et
la course à pied est arrivé
encore une fois un peu par hasard dans
sa vie mais finalement elle est restée
et elle est restée parce qu'elle lui
donne une discipline
le 400 m c'est une discipline
extrêmement difficile qui vous fait
vomir un entraînement qui vous demande
un entraînement acharné
est en prison elle a continué de
s'entraîner il a rajouté de la
souffrance sur la souffrance et ça l'a
obligé à se lever le matin à ne pas
manger n'importe quoi ne pas fumer du
shit et c'était une colonne vertébrale
un twitter voilà qu'il le qui lui a dit
qu'il a maintenue en équilibre justement
cette colonne la donner un accès et s'il
s'en sort ce sera aussi grâce à la
course à pied pour les besoins de votre
enquête pour les besoins de ce livre
vous rencontrez une psy virginie ce
terme bac pour ne pas la nommer qui vous
suggère de vous interroger sur les
raisons qui vous poussent vous à faire
ce travail d'accompagnement presque un
travail de psy vous dit elle
c'est à ce moment là que vous prenez
conscience de cette relation au miroir
oui
vous y attendais pas en fait je vais la
rencontre et parce que elle donne des
ddd conférence à l'insep donc que le
centre de formation des champions
français je me dis pas une psy qui vaut
à l'insep elle va peut-être me donner
une clé un bout des explications sur le
cas de toumani est en fait j'arrive dans
son bureau elle ne me posent des
questions que sur moi et ça me gêne ça
m'énerve mais en sortant elle me
rattrape dans les escaliers elle me dit
ça m'interroge quand même protégez vous
et surtout demandez vous pourquoi vous
faites ça et au même moment la prison on
remarque qu'en fait je suis journaliste
que je n'ai pas le droit de prendre un
parloir famille elle me fait exclure du
parloir ce que je vis comme une
injustice et je me fini par nous poser
la question pourquoi est ce que ça même
à cette obsession pourquoi cette
obsession et j'écris sur un carnet
pourquoi tu fais ça et les réponses qui
viennent
me surprennent vraiment parce que c'est
pas un effet de style du livre à ce
moment là dans l'histoire vraie vous
vous rendez pas rencontre que en effet
ça fait dix ans que je suis journaliste
disons que je cherche des prétextes pour
m'intéresser toujours au même sujet
qu'est la prison enfermement la
délinquance pourquoi certains s'en
sortent et d'autres pas toutes ces
questions qui m'obsède est assez marrant
un de vos copains vous dis encore une
histoire de prison mais quand est ce que
tu vas te décider à te faire coffrer
pour de bon je veux dire oui je me sens
exactement 2 du moment où ce pote m'a
dit ça et je me sens que ça m'avait
touché alors qu'il l'avait dit sur le
ton de la blague mais je savais qu'ils
touchaient quand même une corde sensible
mais c'est vrai qu'est ce qui pousse un
trentenaire a inventé les prisons je
pense qu'en fait trentenaires ou pas
c'est une question de journaliste
pourquoi est ce qu on fait ce métier
parce qu on le fait parce qu'on a envie
parce qu'on cherche une gloire ou à ce
qu'on le fait parce qu'on a quelque
chose en soi qui
qui nous oblige à nous intéresser à
certains sujets il ya des journalistes
qui ne suivent que les questions
d'inceste ou de viols ou deux
journalistes qui ne suivent que que les
questions de mal logement
moi j'ai jamais été rubricards
spécialistes dans un journal mais si je
suis un peu honnête avec moi même ça
fait dix ans que je travaille sur la
prison sur l'univers carcéral faut
savoir pourquoi l or c'est justement à
travers la détention de toumani et en
regardant dans votre dos que vous faites
le lien avec l'arrestation la
condamnation les procès successifs et la
captivité de cet ami d'enfance lorenza
berry que l'on voit ici
oui cette histoire vous a marqué au fer
rouge n'est ce pas en fait c'est une
histoire d'amitié très forte
entre mes parents et des familles
parce que
mais pas les basques de la côte basque
mais basque intérieur et c'est une
histoire sur les années 80 sur les
années 80 et 90 d'un peuple qui se bat
pour exister
et pour s'être ému et pour son autonomie
et d'une d'une jeune femme qui qui a 13
ans de plus que moi
mais dont je connais très bien le petit
frère puisqu'il a le même âge que moi et
moi je suis renvoyé tous les étés là bas
est donc cette cette culture là que je
n'ai pas fait un petit banlieusard de
ris orangis
j'ai envoyé pendant plusieurs semaines
là-bas seul l'été et ce que je découvre
c'est des gamins qui ont mon âge qui
parle qui sont extrêmement politisé qui
parle
plusieurs langues qui ont
une conscience de ce que ça veut dire
que de garder sa langue et sa culture et
qui ont tous des histoires de prison ce
qu'ils ont tous un proche incarcéré lui
chan en l'occurrence sa soeur c'est
lorentxa elle est incarcérée et parce
qu'elle a elle se fait arrêter en 2001
et qu'elle est frappée du sceau de
terroristes de temps après les attentats
du 11 septembre elle est condamnée à
plusieurs dizaines d'années de prison 20
ans de captivité aux 27 27 peng est
retombé à 27 mais qui était monté à plus
de 30 ans et et ça je le vis en étant à
la fois extrêmement proches c'est
terriblement loin parce que ce n'est pas
ma famille ce n'est pas ma culture mais
cette amitié extrêmement forte en thème
des parents et ces gens-là m'oblige à
être concernés on habite à ris orangis
qui est à 5 km de fleury mérogis la plus
grande maison d'arrêt d'europe elle y
est incarcéré son petit frère en 2009 va
la rejoindre et va y être incarcéré
aussi et moi je vais à 20 ans vivre ma
vie de jeune de 20 ans qui fait des
fêtes qui jouent au foot et je peux pas
m'empêcher de me de penser à eux parce
qu'ils sont à 5 km de chez moi mais
qu'est ce qu'elle vit comment vit-elle
voilà ça c'est la grande question est à
cette époque là est-ce que c'est
supportable parce qu'elle tient le coup
ouais
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'avoir sa
jeunesse volée
parce que vous rentrez en prison à 20
ans tout s'arrête et vous vous retrouvez
dans une solitude terrible et et votre
jeunesse s'envole et peut-être votre
avenir s'envole aussi
si vous avez envie de faire des enfants
c'est fini si vous avez envie de d'un
métier c'est fini si vous avez des rêves
c'est terminé et est ce assez
vertigineux et moi à 20 ans
j'avais conscience de cette douleur
parce que c'est too many qui dit ça
vous pouvez croire que ce que vos actes
ne vous n'engage que vous mais c'est
comme un tremblement de terre il ya vous
au centre est derrière tout un tas de
secousses qui viennent toucher les
proches les yeux et sa gelée vue parce
que pour ceux qui ont incarcérés qu'on
appelle les longues peines les liens
familiaux qui se délite des gens qui ne
peuvent plus faire mille kilomètres pour
aller vous voir au parloir et puis
peut-être à petit vous vous retrouvez
seul et un jour vous mourrez et personne
ne vient à votre enterrement et ça
oui ça me touche peut-être sa touche pas
quelqu'un d'autre mais je pense qu'en
tant que journaliste il faut savoir
aussi pourquoi on est attiré par
certains sujets et moi indéniablement la
prison est liée à l'histoire de lorentxa
lié à l'histoire de chan lié à
l'histoire de mon oncle qui a fait
plusieurs années de prison aussi lié à
l'histoire de certains de mes potes avec
lesquels j'ai grandi qui pour des
histoires beaucoup plus banal de trafic
de drogue là j'ai sorti mon livre en
septembre
sur instagram j'ai un copain qui me kim
kim écrit et qui me dit félicitations
ton livre hilali bibliothèque jeudi mais
quelle bibliothèque me dire ah ouais je
t'ai pas dit je suis tombé trafic chez
fleury j'attends mon procès et c'est un
mec un master 2 en droit on a craqué
j'ai grandi donc je peux pas devenu
journaliste
en fait il faut savoir pourquoi on fait
ce métier c'est pas un métier comme les
autres et que on peut pas juste dire ben
non mais je m'intéresse à ça parce que
c'est là que tu où je m'intéresse à ça
parce que parce qu'on m'a demandé de le
faire si tu te lances vraiment sur
certains sujets c'est parce que ça
touche toi bien sûr pourquoi ne pas
avoir poussé votre obsession
comme un art sur fryer par exemple qui a
passé le concours de gardiens de prison
il raconte dans la peau d'un maton ces
mois de détention ou comme une florence
aubenas qui à filtrer le monde est
invisible et qui en rendent compte dans
lequel distraire ce que vous avez pensé
que la titration était une méthode
d'investigation possible pour vous au
contraire vous préféré avancer à visage
découvert pour l'instant je me suis
jamais confronté à un mur qui m'a dit
m'a dit voilà soit tu le fais en
infiltration et de cash pour pouvoir
regarder la vérité
soit tu le fais pas mais il faut
beaucoup de courage aussi pour faire ce
qu'ils ont fait parce que parce que
c'est des mois et des mois dans quête
dans le secret vos proches ne sont pas
au courant
[Musique]
moi je ne suis pas capable je pense de
passer le concours de surveillant
pénitentiaire est de rester un an
n'était capable d'aller tous les
mercredis pendant deux ans oui mais
parce que j'en ai envie mais est ce que
je voudrais en faire mais un type dans
sa cellule et lui dire aller à demain je
suis pas sûr y at il des modèles qui
vous ont malgré tout ouvert la voie on a
cité florence aubenas et ma carrière
j'avais français du côté des américains
on pense bien sûr à aller ni blaye
truman capote normal mais leur
jeannette malcom hunter thompson bien
évidemment ou adrian nicole leblanc et
chez les allemands winter walraff
c'était successivement fait passer pour
un sdf est un travailleur turque tous
ses livres je les ai chamois ouais
donc nous avons transposé la
bibliothèque quelle est celle ou celui
je veux dire celle parce que c'est
florence aubenas en fait elle et elle
est retenue en otage en irak en 2005 et
en 2005 j'ai 16 ans 17 ans
je veux devenir professeur de ps on me
fait comprendre que il faut que je
change de voie alors que pour moi
c'était clair et net que j'allais faire
ce métier parce que il ya un
embouteillage au niveau de
l'administration que trop de monde pas
assez de place et en fait quand elle
sort deux de ses six mois de captivité
au lieu de décrire vie un livre qui va
raconter ça puisque personne ne sait ce
qui lui est arrivé en vendre des
centaines de milliers d'exemplaires elle
dit merci je pourrai jamais vous rendre
tout ce que vous m'avez fait tout ce que
je veux c'est reprendre mon enquête son
enquête celle affaire d'outreau et elle
sort un livre qui s'appelle la méprise
et j'ai à l'époque je lis pas je suis un
mec qui vit en jogging qui jouent au
foot toute la journée mais je me
souviens très bien d'avoir acheté ce
livre est de l'avoir lu d'une traite et
de m'être dit bah ça c'est possible ça
faire ça là ça je veux bien le faire
essayer en tout cas parce que j'avais
trouvé ça extrêmement fort de d'être
capable de vous planter avec elle sur
place à boulogne-sur-mer de vous faire
rencontrer la boulangère le curé d'être
dans le bureau du juge d'instruction et
ça c'est extraordinaire ils savent tous
le faire bien entendu mais mais mon
entrée à moi dans ce milieu en tout cas
dans ce métier là ma porte d'entrée
c'était florent zone est ce qu'avec une
tare est pas de courir vous avez trouvé
en face que vous cherchez mathieu pas
l'un est ce que vous allez au fond dit
autrement trouver une vérité à travers
ce récit qui est aussi une réflexion sur
la résilience et comment on se
reconstruit
c'est bizarre parce que peut-être pour
la première fois je suis j'ai jeu j'ai
mis les pieds hors du journalisme en
rentrant en franchissant trop de lignes
jaunes pour pouvoir maintenant me dire
bon bah voilà ça c'était ça c'est fait
c'est un sujet ça finit dans un livre
pas son suivant toumani gelées encore eu
au téléphone hier je sais qui sort il
est sorti à moins d'un an
on a le même âge sa vie elle continue il
exerce un métier son métier de comptable
ravi oui il est comptable il a repris
l'entraînement il est sur la piste et je
sais que je vais continuer de l'avoir
dans avec moi dans ma vie pendant très
longtemps donc
c'est sûr que ce livre
me marquent beaucoup plus mais aussi
parce que c'est un livre que je n'aurais
pas pu écrire sans dire je j e et 100
mètres de l'un team de un peu de mes
tripes sur la table parce que parce que
parce que parfois il le faut
diriez vous que l'on trouve sa place
dans le monde en regardant d'autres vies
que la sienne
bien sûr oui oui c'est sûr c'est sûr
parce que
parce que c'est c'est en rencontrant
l'autre qu'on se rencontre soi même ses
temps c'est en allant voir c'est en
écoutant d'autres histoires souvent
tragique le journaliste rentrer quand
même souvent dans la vie des gens au
pire moment qu'on on réalise ce qui nous
ce qui nous fait vibrer ce qui nous fait
avancer
c'est quelque chose c'est une chance
d'avoir
cette opportunité de rentrer dans la vie
des autres vous êtes né la même année
que too many coulibaly vous avez grandi
au même endroit vous êtes dites-vous
joliment des compatriotes de banlieue
est pourtant l'un est devenu journaliste
écrivain l'autre championne du monde 400
m haies délinquants avant
de devenir un comptable pourquoi
certains s'en sortent et d'autres pas
c'est l'autre question qui vous monte
est ce que cette question là vous l'avez
résolu ça tient beaucoup à l'entourage
quand même je peux parler que pour moi
mais
bon nous on voulait pas sur l'or à la
maison mais j'avais mes deux parents qui
était la 1ère institutrice en maternelle
mon père qui est éducateur pour le
ministère de la justice
et si je disais bon j'aimerais devenir
astronaute probablement qu'ils m'ont
radis battant on va essayer trop de
numéros de la nasa et ça c'est
extrêmement fort il faut pas le
sous-estimer d'avoir l'anc ou des
proches qui vous encouragent qui vous
soutiennent chivu rigole pas sonné quand
vous dites j'aimerais devenir
journaliste alors qu'ils en connaissent
pas en selle
c'est ce qui permet d'avoir un peu
confiance en soi et la confiance en soi
et est primordial là dedans
tout manier pour le connaître il a
l'intelligence pour exercer absolument
n'importe quel métier
mais il a d'abord commencé en étant
traité de vaux rien fait vous traitez de
vauriens pendant 18 ans et il ya peu de
chances que vous ayez atteint des
sommets quoi donc
je suis pas pédopsychiatre il est vrai
que tous jouent dans l'enfance je sais
qu'en tout cas pour moi j'ai été mis
dans des conditions qui m'ont permis d'
un jour de m'autoriser à me dire bah
tiens pourquoi pas un journaliste
simplement en ayant lu un livre de
florence aubenas
toumani cinquième d'une fratrie de 18 il
avait d'abord l'amour de ses parents à
partager
le mot de la fin ça serait de tahar
haddad courir
ouais en fait ce titre vient aussi de
c'était ma soeur qui m'avait dit sera le
jour j'avais signé mon cdi à 21 ça
voulait dire un peu ne t'arrête pas sur
tes lauriers non plus donc je pense que
c'est un bon conseil surtout surtout
mathieu pénin ne vous arrêtez pas
d'écrire à c'est très gentil merci à
vous
[Musique]